may have heard overnight Stephen Hawking
the best-known space scientist since
Albert Einstein died this morning at his
home in England he was 76 Britain's
Guardian calls Hawking's cosmologies
brightest star he dedicated his life to
helping ordinary people understand the
secrets of the universe hawking lived
most of his life in a wheelchair but he
once said in my mind I am free
he sure seemed like it NASA tweeted this
morning his theories unlocked a universe
of possibilities that we and the world
are exploring may you keep flying like
Superman in microgravity as you said two
astronauts on the space station in 2014
Mark Phillips is in London taking a look
back at Hawking's extraordinary life and
his work mark good morning
good morning well Stephen Hawking he
hadn't actually been able to speak for
decades but everybody knew that voice
he was probably the best-known
scientific mind of modern times and the
most famous disabled person in the world
Stephen Hawking with his wheelchair and
his computer synthesized voice was an
instantly recognizable figure if you
were first time becoming the subject of
a popular movie Hawking was born in
Oxford England in 1942 he was a 21 year
old PhD student when he was diagnosed
with amyotrophic lateral sclerosis lou
gehrig's disease and told he had just a
year or two to live he not only lived
five decades longer his 1988 book a
brief history of time explaining the
mysteries of the universe in layman's
language became an international
bestseller and made him an unlikely
worldwide celebrity when he turned 60 he
did a star turn with Ed Bradley on CBS
News 60 minutes but for me that is quite
an achievement I never thought I would
get so Herr Hawking was one of President
Obama's first recipients of the Medal of
Freedom
because he had overcome disability to
push the boundaries of science professor
Stephen Hawkins
was a brilliant man in a mediocre
student a mediocre student with a list
of scientific accomplishments going back
to the beginning of time itself
his work on the origins of the universe
and on black holes in space defined how
we now understand them yet he was
somehow never awarded a Nobel Prize
always fascinated by space
he took a zero gravity flight in 2007
the first time in 40 years he could move
without the chair popular culture here I
come he had a role on Star Trek
I caught I don't make arithmetic
mistakes are you saying but he knew he
had made it on the Simpsons I wanted to
see your utopia
but it's the science that will endure
then here's a fun fact Stephen Hawking
was born on the 300th anniversary of the
death of Galileo and has died on Albert
Einstein's birthday Gale it's like he
said they may be order in the universe
after all I totally agree with that mark
and they said his nickname was Einstein
back in the day when he was a kid I saw
an interview early this morning with
Diane Sawyer he said it's message to his
kids was never give up work it gives you
purpose and meaning in life and without
work your life is empty without it so
true and he lived his life that way yeah
I mean he expanded our minds in in a way
that we're gonna be trying to figure out
for probably as long as he was alive
yeah he did say that I wanted to show
people they not be limited by their
physical handicaps as long as they are
not disabled in spirit he was such a
risk-taker in many ways the example of
that very nicely done Mark Phillips
thank you again